all right your bullet cap podcast bullet
cap show
one of the hottest well i would say
probably the hottest group in l.a the
the hottest group duo i don't know do we
consider you guys a group or a duo
clan it's the clan uh
blue bucks clan is here welcome uh
congratulations man um i remember
hearing about you guys i want to say the
first time i heard of y'all
was probably like mid-2019
ish like right you know what i'm saying
i think you guys really started to heat
up right before the pandemic like really
started to get crazy crazy
um correct me if i'm wrong but when i
first started like saw your guys [ __ ]
there was
like more you guys as far as like on the
rapping side is that right
no it's always you guys have always been
the two main guys but there's other
people in in in the clan or
yeah i hate to that sounds crazy as a
white guy asking that question
there's other people in the clan we're
the only ones rapping though
you guys are the only two rapping
yo what happened in the uh you guys got
you guys threw a party during the
during the this kobe [ __ ] and and and
what happened
we thought party what was he talking
about
so that wasn't y'all's party
but you guys have attended plenty of so
la people obviously
from the outside looking in we like
quote unquote shut the [ __ ] down out
here but we really ain't been shut the
[ __ ] down here there's been loopholes
lots of airbnb parties strip clubs have
still been going crazy this whole time
they're just like secret locations and
[ __ ] like have you guys been moving
around like kind of normally during the
pandemic
yeah but here
yeah but at the same time we've been
kind of we're talking to mike talking
about staying to ourselves you know like
staying at the house tonight in the
studio
it ain't really much to do so like we
ain't just gonna just be
doing anything or going anywhere but
hey i wouldn't say it changed our you
know we still do what we want to do
y'all covered it all no neither
wow i caught that [ __ ] for the show i
had that
[ __ ] those people was catching it for a
minute but i don't be hearing about it
no more like
i don't hear about people catching in no
more right now i feel like it was like a
regular uh
coat like regularly i couldn't i just
couldn't smell her taste
for how long a week no it was like it
was like three weeks
damn yeah it sucks that's weird though
cause like once you get it
then you get rid of it and it's like
it's done like yeah i i i was moving
around
you know freely and then i got it and
then you know i sat
took a little seat for a few weeks came
back and it right got right back to it
um so you guys just dropped the new uh
record with a shout out to hit boy man
hip boy is my bro
who had a crazy year last year and is
continuing his year this year uh
but uh how'd this record come to be with
with hit boy first of all talk about how
you guys collaborated and then we'll get
to the quail feature
uh just working just out here working
you know we end up linking up
shout out you know put it together uh
just went to the studio he played the
beat first bit he played
that was the first one you guys just
went right in
so played it for a reason
is your guys how's your guys's writing
process do you guys go in and like
like write anything down or is it all
punch-ins or like how do you guys record
you got to hold your mic bro it's all
punched you're talking into the
backwoods
it's all punching uh you guys punching
that line by the way i'm feeling the
beat really
right if we like we are in the studio
right now
and they making the beat they're playing
some beats
like we're gonna we're gonna be chilling
until one of the bees move us like oh
yeah this
all right let's go once you spark
something like oh you got to go off
one line like you be in here playing
around just saying
[ __ ] yeah if it's like if i'm like oh
that was
you got to say that right right right
off of that
boom go record it would you guys
consider like a friendly competition
between the two y'all when you when you
guys
like like record but uh i would say we
we uh uh we are like already like um
so we won't make no bad songs i would
say or say nothing
that i you know i'm saying we uh tell
each other right there like nah say
something different
say something like we would rather the
song be a good
song we ain't like trying to like oh i'm
trying to make one verse better than his
right you guys like take each other's
criticism yeah right thing in there
like it ain't no no ego [ __ ] yeah yeah
if you say something i'll be like man
say some harder [ __ ] tonight like
that's really all they be you know yeah
once he say something like that then i
know life
i gotta i gotta come with something
like that mean come harder like that's
it regular you saying how did you guys
meet up
kids football
and then i know you you played football
like like
did you play in college i know you
played where'd you play it
played at robert morris university so
you you took football pretty serious
was that like uh i mean that's kind of
always the dream as a kid it's like you
know make it the nfl or the nba oh yeah
for me it was the nba and then i was
like 15 and i was like come on man
i'm like an average sized white guy
she's not going to happen to me like you
know
but like um how how like you know that
like football
as a hustle is crazy just you know the
discipline that
you have to have to be to make it as far
as you did even you know what i'm saying
um at what point in time did you realize
that like football might not be like
you know in your cards long term yeah
[ __ ] when i got to college and just
really like
just realizes like this [ __ ] like like
the coaches
you know that they be acting weird and
[ __ ] and it's like
you just don't want to play nowhere like
i've been over this [ __ ] bro
take the fun out of it they really take
the fun out to [ __ ] like a lot of
coaches be like that so then people even
like [ __ ] him i don't want to play
football anymore you got to wait
you had you had like a wild like like a
like a
og old school type coach that was on
your head like
yeah the little cultures that be on you
about every little thing
then it's just like you got to wake up
early it's just like bro i'm tired of
[ __ ]
yo that's that's why i didn't play
football in high school it was like it
was a year-round thing
and then you had to be to school way
long like you had to be at school all
the [ __ ] time
i was like i'm trying to go school is
fun like that [ __ ] is cool
once you get to college and they start
like not this is too much bro
you gotta worry about grades and [ __ ]
y'all worry about a lot
damn everything who's y'all's football
team cowboys
like players players i like a gang of
the players though
like who's your favorite player man
my favorite player for yeah
all right who comes to mind i like uh
you got to hold the [ __ ] mic
bro now i know why he wanted that mic i
like tyra matthew
oh honey badger that's my brother right
i like players like that you know yeah
with the swagger mark jackson yeah
lamborghini smith
yeah he got to get off tick-tock man
that's his other thing man uh
carrie vincent coming out of lsu
um the record with cuevo obviously we
talked about the hit boy aspect of it
how did how did um
cuevo end up on the song was that
something because you guys
share the share the label now you know
what i'm saying shout out to
walked
um i felt like maybe him and his boy had
a session
right going on at that same time or
maybe he was a little early
right and then he was like he knew who
he was
so it was like supernatural yeah i
didn't expect him to know who he was we
liked it
we looked at the corner we wasn't
prepared to just watch him work like
hell yeah like yo we want to see what
you're doing what's your process like
yeah
yeah and he like let's do something
hey i know you're watching the interview
right now thank you for watching we got
to interrupt this for a special
uh announcement from our good good good
sponsors over at odd socks
i have all socks on my feet as we speak
these are nwo socks you know i mean the
wolf pack you know somehow
shout out to um odd socks though if
you're watching this
go to oddssoxofficial.com and buy the
most comfortable socks in the world
and i truly do mean that these right
here these are the most comfortable
socks in the world
these are the basics they're just plain
[ __ ] great
you know they got all the licenses
spongebob wwe
just everything you could ever want yeah
i mean i'm just throwing socks at nico
blitz right now our producer is filming
this
but uh look go to oddssoxofficial.com
trust me they got the masks the boxers
everything you need my personal favorite
that i've been loving
is they got the naruto and i'm not even
into that [ __ ]
but the socks are fly and the street
fighter socks crazy licenses
oddssocksofficial.com keyword bootleg
kev
right now save 20 off at checkout um
you guys had a lot of luck i mean you
know when
i remember when you guys started a
bubble like hearing conversations about
certain people trying to
sign you like i'm sure there was a lot
of competition to sign
you guys to to a deal um
what was that like being courted because
you know
it's almost like some free agency [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying it was crazy
like how many different labels did you
guys talk to anyone you could think of
all of them all of them independent
labels
and the major levels it was crazy that
was a crazy time
that had to be dope though
waking up every day like damn these
[ __ ] wait what they offer
like oh [ __ ] why'd you guys end up going
with uh with capital
just made sense at the end of the day
that's all that matters you know
everything makes sense on paper was it
the bag
because sometimes the bag ain't always
with like you know i always tell artists
like
you the bag got to get paid back you
know what i'm saying you got to recoup
that so
sometimes it's about it's not you know
that's a part of it but
a lot of it is also like fit you know
what i'm saying like right
some of these labels are so big it's the
rosters are so extensive that it's like
hard to be a priority i think capital
like
they almost need somebody outside of qc
to get behind you know what i'm saying
they got and qc is like you know a
machine you know what i'm saying but
like
i think you i think that was a great
choice yeah so we got out the blue
you know yeah it's our machine right now
we about to go crazy you guys will start
signing artists
you know never know into it after we
get through the door there it is sorry
we get through the door you know
he got the mic down here
oh my man nah i think um you know
especially in la i feel like the last
like
five years it's been dope to just
witness you know we always would hear
how
atlanta's sticks together and we'd
always hear how la's so divided
and new york is so divided but i think
that this entire
for the most part obviously i mean
obviously nothing's ever going to be
perfect but i feel like you know
everyone's making music together and
everyone seems to be supporting each
other when it comes to like guys like
yourself one take jay
ruchi you know that that whole new
generation at la
rap it feels real camaraderie of like
everyone's kind of in it together do you
guys feel the same way
yeah i mean them all the homies they're
all cool all the [ __ ] cool
outside of music like so
that's how we met like you know kind of
like that so
they just been the same since you know
everybody right then it's
same cool so like we pretty much cool
with everybody everybody kind of
either he knew him or i knew him before
like before all this like we knew each
other like we we know already knew
people
right right right you know so and you
guys you guys are
originally weren't trying to rap right
which i saw some people play football
like what i'm saying like i saw some of
you guys were trying to manage some
artists or some [ __ ] right
our homies was rapping before and we
started like
um like trying to like help them out
really
like really they wouldn't they had no
support really pretty much and nobody
right right right
we really start seeing like alright the
music like this [ __ ] kind of the music
scene is like kind of where it's at like
so what year did you guys start rapping
2019
that was the first year you started
rapping first charlie rapping
so like the first time you ever got in a
got on on been to the studio
2019 bro yeah
that [ __ ] is crazy and how was it like
was it just
natural like we gonna do this together
what does it end up happening really
like
i just always i always went to the
studio with him
so like we just end up making songs
together
and then like all the other homies like
y'all [ __ ] sound good together like
that [ __ ] hard bro
right right right right [ __ ] you we
gonna keep doing this
just start having fun with it that's so
crazy we're having fun with it really
making
making songs just for us and the homies
that's just to
send them to them like we wouldn't put
them out put them it would just be
on everyone's phones yep still it's
still like for us you know
yeah other people happen to like it but
we still making this [ __ ]
that [ __ ] you know how hot people are
right now watching this they've been
rapping 15 20 years like yo man they'd
be hot
hey congrat you know what's crazy the
same thing happened with mustard
mustard's first uh beet was it was a
patty cake record
damn fruit yeah yeah i mean [ __ ] if you
ask him he'll tell you
i heard the mustard before that no
yeah he was djing but i'm saying like
just right off the rip just
just caught one off the rip that's
that's popping in the streets
no have you guys um you know
with the buzz and just just like have
you guys noticed people start to switch
up at all
like around you or or like things start
to get weird the more popping you get
whether it's with with friends with
family with just
[ __ ] changes have you guys noticed that
yet
yeah this [ __ ] crazy man i'll be feeling
like we
was made for this [ __ ] though [ __ ] it
ready for whatever
right um kevin durant quoting y'all [ __ ]
that had to be pretty crazy because you
guys are sports fans that feels crazy
and kd's like you know he's one of them
guys
he's like top 10 top 11 player all time
you know what i'm saying you guys see
what he did to michael rappaport
i've seen a little bit but i ain't
really reading to it
bro he went in
he said pull up he called him a [ __ ]
guzzling [ __ ]
no in his dms he said pull up he sent
him the address
kevin kevin durant was like pull up your
wife don't respect you you [ __ ] guzzling
[ __ ]
i was like oh my god that's that's cause
he'd be talking he really be talking
[ __ ] though rapper
oh rappaport
i don't respect the fact that you talk
[ __ ] but then someone comes at you and
you leak the [ __ ] crazy [ __ ] though
disrespectful like if he posted the deal
like oh like look at kd he's supposed to
be such a good guy but look how he
bullied me
but michael all michael rappaport does
is bully people
talk down on everybody i'm assuming you
guys are laker fans
no i'm i like the lake i like lebron
james i'm gonna say that
you're a lebron fan i'm a lebron fan too
so i'm not even gonna lie
mine i'm from phoenix so i grew up a
sons fan so i've hated the lakers my
entire life
so but but i always the suns have sucked
for a long time
so i've always rooted for every lebron
team right so i had like
i had to make a business decision when
he got when he went to the lakers i'd
say you know what
that's what everybody needed man i'm
gonna have to put put aside any feelings
about the lakers i got
as long if they play the suns i'm
[ __ ] with the suns but i'm i'm i want
to see my guy braun
get i wanted to at least see him get
sick you know what i'm saying oh yeah
no it's shout out to lebron man um
who's some people out here uh in la that
um you know i feel like we always talk
about uh
especially in hip-hop there's not a lot
of real friends right there's people
you'll see in the studio you'll see at
the club and you're like yo we got to
get up we got to work together you might
do records with people but like who
would you guys consider like actual
homies
if this [ __ ] went away that's in the
industry if anybody
[ __ ] i'll be with my homies yeah i'll be
with them one day
everybody else just saw some some hip
hop should we be together every day like
we won't even really be doing much like
that you know i'm gonna be hanging with
[ __ ]
they cool though but i'll be with my
homies
how fun was the was the video shoot with
cuevos it was seemed like it was
it was uh it was a good time
cool like everything was right like the
show was cool yeah trailers was this was
before uh
was sweetie around i don't know about it
i'm just asking she wasn't at the video
or nothing
man shout out yo it's been a very
eventful week
just for just i do radios so it's a lot
of [ __ ] been flying a little nasdaq
shipping popping sweeties
and quavo scrapping in the elevator
should be [ __ ] up man
shout out to cuevos shout out to cuevo
uh shout out to y'all
hey introduce the new record though um
let's get into it man let's
let's run it on the bullet calf show
it's a blue bus clan man feature quavo
produced by hit boys called lilly go
check it out right now maybe right here
[Music]
let's go let's go